the media just gets everything wrong and
every now and again you can go back and
find Beautiful Moments of the lies being
exposed in real time so here's where I
want to give credit where credit is due
you remember Matt Lauer Matt Lauer was
beloved by
mainstream media for like 20 years
hosted the Today show I guess he ended
up harassing a couple women or something
he's gone now okay fine he was me too is
what it is but here he actually did a
pretty freaking decent job this is
amazing so this is video from 2016.
with Matt Lauer on The Today Show asking
then Twitter CEO Jack Dorsey if they
censor individuals this is this is just
spectacular and just watch this
knowing the backdrop of what we have
learned over the last couple days so let
me ask you point blank does Twitter
censor the content of its users does it
hide what it would consider inflammatory
comments whether they be social or
political absolutely not Twitter has
always been about controls people can
follow whoever they want and it's our
job to make sure they see the most the
most important things and the things
that don't matter to them so anybody can
say anything on Twitter the company does
not go in there and take certain things
out that can be dangerous well there's
certain there's certainly tweets that
promote violence which is against our
terms of service and people have
controls to block and people have
controls to mute but what about the
company who decides the difference
between criticism and hate these are the
these are the individuals so you can
follow who you want and if it's
something you want to see you continue
to follow okay you really need to
understand I I think that video is going
to be used in a court of law against him
and and the company not only is he lying
there because he also like it's very
obvious that he's like he's basically
saying we don't do anything you can
decide what to do meaning you can block
you can mute you can unfollow somebody
but then he said at this and this is the
line if you're if you're a lawyer
interested in First Amendment and any of
this stuff Tech you this is the line our
job is they see the most important
things
well if your job is that they see the
most important things by default you're
ensuring that they won't see other
certain things because you're deciding
what's most important when most people
got on Twitter the idea was you are
going to follow people and see a purely
chronological feed with no manipulation
that's what you will see but their job
became to make sure you see the most
important things
well that means some things aren't going
to be as important so we are
manipulating and now we know that shadow
Banning exists that there were actual
tools at Twitter to make sure certain
people couldn't be seen or would be uh
suspended or whatever it might be and
that the government was coordinating all
over it so the reason I showed you that
is because I want to give Matt Lauer
credit Matt Lauer did a fine job there
but usually what the media does is
Elevate people who are bad and wrong
about everything